au lac à thal so squeeze aujourd'hui je
te donne un style espagnol si ça dérange
tout dézinguer des sceaux sur god and
glory en jouant un papa avec qui amène
son fils à l'école son fils il à
l'arrière du vélo comme un plus
exactement pareil et sur notre-dame y
avoir plein de pièges qui enfle à
esquiver ce qu'on appelle ceci en fait
voilà c'est le happy who is next gen
quoi elle cet article un mode de garde
et nous ont pas manqué à temps se fait
trop bizarre de voir en train d ok on y
va donc là on joue john et jimmy woha
temps avec ses à sa possible à jouer au
jimmy [ __ ] j'aimais pu s'achever que
cet été le coup le conte est avec moi sa
scolarité à ben voilà c'est très bien
aller du mais on va à l'école on y vend
willy tu apprends qu est un gangster mon
pif ou des marionnettes mon fils mon
gars ça j'ai acheté une poupée sur
amazon je prends pour office comme si
opaque on peut sauter auquel aura tourné
sa wii attendu mais quand vainqueurs
vont s'envoler
on s'en bat les couilles du oui ces
bandits ces poissons ça n'a aucun
rapport
merde nantua bienvenue toi bien papa est
plus fort que ça voilà encore gelée
royale et tuba tout va bien du bit soit
bien aller du mit à ton père du milieu
ton père tu dis à ton père à l'est du
mur on y va iolo style jimmy o comment
j'ai fait ça au mon dieu qu'est ce que
c'est que ça j'arrive à pédaler au
machin et demi un problème donc tu vas
aller à l'école et tuer les drapeaux
comme ton père du mythique ouailles à ça
sur le sur notre chemin du mit je ne
sais pas non non attendez ça j'aime et
c'est géant
boudaha tu pourras jamais tant mieux la
ville de vélo comme son frère jamie on y
retourne contre toi mon gars monfils
quoi tu avais du billy bordel un peu de
courage à temps mais beck était tombé
sur un brin d'herbe tranché c'est le
même brin d'herbe que tu mets entre août
et pousse ta paye tu souffles ça fait du
bruit n'a jamais fait ça ce truc
d'attardés bateau mieux qui met en ondes
sur tes gens vont s'y aventurent remonte
sur tes jambes djebe tu ta g aucune
autorité saint-françois on va faire
s'ennuie à aux esquives aux mondiaux à
l'échouement à l'herbe je suis en plein
air tout seul à côté des jambes de mon
fils on se baisse et ce qui va à l'homme
ça monsieur en fait mais qu'elles vont
chez décédé là on y va ok allez cette
fois d'union passe merbau attention
jimmy
au t3 dijon ce fils papa coutu sans toi
jimmy tel père tel fils je perds la tête
passe à côté mais là je lèverai ont
perdu ajuste sa tête coiffée j'aimerais
bien passer ma eckstein voyez y avait un
vrai passé avec style auberge au oui oh
oui c'est pas grave tu me dis papa est
un produit et missiles sait conduire à
une main jimmy voilà qu'on aille ou from
my yahoo à l'apparence est compliqué
jimmy tu vas arriver qu'un tee-shirt
rouge mais qu'ils soient blancs l on y
va on y va on y va on y va on y va papa
te mets bien cousins on atterrit au
niveau d'étude allant soir au riz jimmy
waite je me pose est alors on continue
notre périple
finalement pour aller à l'école l'enjeu
porte sur la voiture ce qui est plus
pratique instaurée pour de vrai c'est
quoi ça ça fait pas mal ça pardon
raidlight z a on peut mettre une live au
monsieur incroyable at en fait c'est
plus dur de te prendre que des civets ce
tri à les humains continuent à temps
mais ces huiles et qui a vu les soldats
c'est quoi ta wii ricane mcenroe et
jimmy la london school school dati dont
j avais tu t'enflammes et pourquoi tu as
voulu danser c'est un cabinet le sol
jamie ouais c'était par engrenage
insurgé me regarde au charbon perd c'est
fini c'est pas fini par do you la dure
l'eau stagne à putte un violon je suis
désolé dit on va prendre tellement chère
julie va pas vous l'êtes impressionné
mais il aurait pas dû en fait je pense
fouillaient toulalan fait faux et c'est
une rampe
voilà moi je voulais faire un sommet en
fait une rencontre au niveau à tout doux
et là on se lance l'entente l'instant je
dis mais on y va oui oh oui oui tu fais
ça tu me dis à tes copains à acheter
c'est quoi ça du week end with jimmy
esquive papa
voilà retrouvez moi tous les joueurs à
la bouche et le kremlin bicêtre on va
leur montrer qui on est oh oui ça tient
change d'avis jimmy change d'habits
d'avis qu'il faut que je t'avais dit de
changer tes fréquentations qui sont
mauvaises qui sont nuisibles lutins
renfort on y va on y va on ira on saura
sauvé d'un très grand la la fumette à
aller à l'essai perdu s'est perdu et
perdu ce pardon mais bon oh on est bon
dit mais on est bon vite
[Musique]
en plus il vient dégager mais quel fan
vidéo exceptionnelle je tire mon fils en
voir hier que je suis un caïd swag
hockey seulement la belge fait partie
ils achètent pas on va mon gars mais on
va le faire on parle de violence du
bitume attendant je n'entends pas on
parle de violence du mil et la petite
catégorie n'était pas allé mais ça vous
a plu en tout cas super sympa serment
une sorte de happy with bas vu des en 3d
quoi voilà c'est clairement inspiré peu
wyss avec le papa et son fils à
l'arrière je crois qu'on pourra jouer
d'autres persos ci qui ne sont pas dans
public n'hésitez pas à soutenir le
développeur en votant pour son jeu sur
steam greenlight voilà pour qu'ils aient
une chance qu'un jour son jeu se
retrouve sur steam ce qui offre une
bonne visibilité pour ses développeurs
n'ayant les rois de la mort les envois
du love je voudrais d'abord vous aurez
du love je vous ai fait une prochaine
vidéo
portez vous bien géré tout le monde
[Musique]